It is an incredible view that we have
here being able to look at the screen and
see all of the faces of
people around the world.
And it's inspiring that you could
run an event like this online.
[MUSIC]
>> What a great group.
Thank you so much for all participating.
I just want to say that you have actually
transformed my view of virtual education.
>> Man, I mean,
it has been an experience for
the years that it's totally memorable and
unforgettable.
>> You can do anything that's truly
authentic to you, and your strengths and
your interests and passions and
it will serve the world.
[MUSIC]
>> Okay, let's give a cheers to Naomi.
>> Thank you so much.
I'm speechless and
I'm just crying [LAUGH].
>> The revelation was that
you could actually form
a community of people who were from all
around the world in different time zones.
Completely spread out,
geographically dispersed, but yet
who would become a whole that was
more than the sum of the parts.
>> Community is such a special one and
I know that a lot of you
feel this way as well.
>> Thanks to all of you and cheers.
>> We'll go 3,
2, 1, cheers,
[MUSIC]